وفقا صحيفه بوليتيكو فاجتماع بيض
وسالينسكي ياخذ بعد تاريخيا مختلفا كونه
اول لقاء حضوري منذ الحرب سيتم من خلاله
تعزيز الدعم ليكياف سيانين قالت انزلينسكي
يقوم بهذه الزياره المفاجئه والمثيره
لواشنطن لحشد الدعم الامريكي
وللدفاع عن اوكرانيا في المرحله المقبله
لقاء يحتمل ان يعلن بعده او ان يعلن بعده
بعيدا عن حزمه جديده من المساعدات بقيمه
مليارات دولار لاوكرانيا تشمل نظام بيجريت
لدفاعات الجويه المتطوره ستغير من
التطورات الميدانيه الحاصله
في ما يقولوا المسؤولون الامريكيون ان
التسليط الضوء على دعم اداره بيض
لاوكرانيا في هذه المرحله امر بالغ
الاهميه لمواصله كسب تاييد من الحلفاء
الغربيين في اوروبا في ما ينتقدها اخرون
ويسرون على تقليل الدعم لانه ياتي على
حساب الدافعي ضرائب الامريكيين وهي مهمه
قد لا تكون مستحيله امام الرئيس الاوكراني
لاقناع بعض المتشككين او المشككين او على
الاقل قياده الحزب الجمهوري باهميه
استمرار الدعم الامريكي لبلاده خاصه ان لا
امل يلوح لانهاء تلك الحرب قريبا
[موسيقى]